all right and
uh be patient with us please as i get
our
live stream started for our linkedin
live audience
as you can see we have
inaudible
here with us and i'll introduce her
shortly
so
one moment for this process
now we are live on youtube and linkedin
as well as with our live webex audience
our introduction my name is stuart creek
i'm a
marketing manager here at simply learn
and with us today is
founding head of the department of mass
communication at partner women's college
she's also a meditate television
presenter she will
speak to us today about
how to crack any interview to grab your
dream job in 2022
just let you know you can enter
questions from it into the
q a
panel in webex you can also do that into
your comments on the live streams on
youtube and linkedin
and we will try to get to those at the
end of the presentation
um
we're going to ask a couple of questions
one now and one later
but menadi of course will have more for
you during her presentation
but let's just start off with
a simple two-part question first off how
much experience do you have
in the workplace
whatever position or job your
you've been in
and also we're asking a check-in
question we've been asking all through
the
pandemic as
lockdowns come and go surges come and
rise and fall
um i want to see how people are holding
up to that
and
about 15 more seconds on the pull
and we'll close the poll in about five
seconds
so here is the result of the poll i mean
not an interesting
back here is that uh half or more of our
audience
are people with five or more years of
experience in the workplace
so we have a fairly seasoned audience
um and of course it's good to see that
pretty much everybody is doing
okay or
at least
okay
for anybody who's in the third category
we hope that
what manati has to share with you today
will
improve your outlook for
your job prospects in the future and
with that i'm going to
[Music]
introduce her briefly before we
turn the presentation over to her so
um
i will actually allow you to describe
yourself other than i'm just going to
mention you're a an expert career
counselor and
you've been
doing news bulletins on buddhism for
about 20 years so now so
you have a great deal of experience in
communications but also
that's putting you in touch with
just a broad cross-section of people in
business industry and
other sectors so
we're very lucky to have you here and
and welcome
uh you're on mute i'm sorry it was a
thing that happens when we did a lot
that's better thank you stuart i think
i'm perfectly audible
yes
yeah so thank you for your introduction
it was really lovely
and hello guys i hope you all are doing
great as you have already mentioned that
you are doing very good today
so as i can see that most of you are
seasoned but still uh there are certain
things that always you know we have to
understand and grow muscles so could you
please allow me to share the screen
stuart
yes you should have the sharing
privilege now
and i see your screen
so
we need to understand interview the term
first
that has come from
interview is a french term
and
it's a combination of two words enter
and wire enter is between and voir is
view interview then interview
so it is a process that is done overly
that all of you know all of us know also
it is fairly structured it's a
face-to-face communication and
coincidental session so many times you
know since i conduct mock interviews too
so many times can just come and ask me
that why everything is written in the
resume still why we are asked to
interview so if the question is very you
know answer is very simple that
it is an opportunity
for interaction and understanding the
job seeker because any company any
organization
should know the job seeker first because
maybe we are interested in joining some
organization that organization might not
need us so that way it is the best way
to understand us is this suitability we
might be very good at you know certain
thing but we might not be that good but
the
must not might not be that suitable for
the organization judge efficiency level
so this is the way we can judge the
efficiency level of the candidates
and this is of course the best option
available because there is no other
procedure through which we get to know
the candidates then
communication skills we can understand
by asking questions that the person is
comfortable talking to people because in
any organization we are supposed to talk
without interaction we cannot get any
job done then also it is the way we can
assess confidence and the comfort level
of the
the candidate
because
unless you are confident maybe you are
very efficient very talented but if you
are not confident to uh
to deliver the job well then
that has to be developed it is very very
important then additional traits of
information many times there are certain
traits that we possess but we do not
mention in our cv so that also sometimes
we find out through the interview and
the most important thing is that since
communication is two-way process so we
also get to know from the candidates
that what is what are their expectation
so this is very very important this is
why interviews are conducted
then the traits that make or mar
so we need to have communication skills
analytical skills
behavioral aspects
proper body language professionalism and
of course attitude
trait that make her mark first
impression people often say don't know
first impression might not be that
important but recently in 2021 last year
only one study was conducted among 2000
you know a chart professionals it was
found that 83 percent of people agreed
that yes first impression does matter
and one percent did not agree but that
means we have to pay attention to the
first expression
so you got it right you are being judged
the instant you step in the moment you
enter people start judging you how you
enter what type of address you're
wearing your wheel your gate how you
come how you pull the chair and how you
sit everything is being washed and this
is done in a couple of seconds only so
when you enter you should always project
an impression of confidence and trust
you should walk in a manner you should
look at the interview in a manner so
that a trust is built between the
interviewer and the interviewee
press to develop these are the traits we
must develop because
in interview
loyalty is very very important like uh
if
a an organization organization always
look for the loyal candidates because
the person who they are going to hire
must be loyal to the organization then
integrity is again very important
sincerity how much sincere you are to
your work to your studies to your
academic you know life and and of course
your previous employer
in in your previous job how much
sincerity you have shown is also very
important then adaptability how quickly
your adapt to the new situation
because in the previous you might have a
different uh you know situation a
different you know entire thing is
different and now in the new current
open education the new organization how
quickly you can adapt it then of course
kindness also plays a vital role
especially post covid this has become
very very important that how much kind
you are to other fellow members then
persistence is also very very important
emotional intelligence that is again
that your iq takes you here but it is
your emotional intelligence that you
know keeps in any organization then then
the tolerance level because uh nowadays
we the life has become you know so fast
and stressful also so we are getting
little intolerance so tolerance level
also we have to see that how much
tolerant we are and this test can be
done and open-mindedness we have to be
broad and this trade has to be developed
because when we are working uh when we
are like students and all so that time
we do not you know pay attention to such
traits but when we are going as a job
seeker these are the traits that
any organization look forward to in the
candidate they are going to select
then equality what qualities have to be
inculcated that
fast learner like a in in strength many
times you know most of the time it is
asked also that
what is your strength please you know
describe your key strengths so then fast
learner then self-starter team player
go-getter dependable hard-working result
and target oriented these are the
qualities you know some of you you can
relate yourselves it is not necessary
that you need to have all those
qualities that i have mentioned but yes
some of maybe you're fast learner you
might not be that self-starter but you
may be a team player maybe you are a gay
a go-getter
you maybe might not be that hard working
but dependable
you you you may be you know target
oriented so it is not necessary that you
need to have all the traits but you have
to see as per you have to be very honest
about you know choosing your trait and
that you have to include inculcate in
your life then
see in communica communication skills
play a vital role like how since you
have come for you have been invited and
called for an interview that means
the interviewer the organization has
gone through your resume your cv
properly after a thorough appraisal look
only then you are invited you are asked
for the interview so that then what
happens that how will you do how will
you show because everything is already
mentioned in your cv everything is
already meditation then your resume then
you have to see that which way sometimes
it also happens that you know 50 of
something and you are able to
communicate the 50 of your talent but if
sometimes it also happens you know so
much but you are not able to deliver
that way so for here communication
skills very important that whatever you
know and whatever the way the question
is as you are able to answer well and
and you must be able to give a
satisfactory answer so for this as we
say that communication
skills it's called skills because you
know reading writing speaking and
listening so reading writing you have
already done you have already
you know qualified you are
you know that academically you have done
the thing here it is speaking and
listening that matters more so you are
able to speak well and you are able to
listen well also so for this you need to
practice practice practice that is the
only way you can do it is not that that
just you know before a day of interview
or before a couple of day or some
interview you just go and face it it
requires lot of practice you should have
some questions frequently ask questions
can make a list of those questions and
practice a lot and see that each time
the more you practice the better
communicator you become because many
times it also happens that the things
are then your mind and when you come out
the interview you know hall then you
realize oh my god i should have answered
this way oh my god i have left this
particular thing so for this practice
you know is the mantra that you have to
practice a lot and list those questions
and and each time you stand before the
mirror or maybe you sitting sometimes
standing just practice or maybe you can
have somebody in front of you maybe your
friend and and ask the friend to ask the
questions and you answer them
then
the next point is
very important that a proper body
language
because uh
you you whatever you say that must align
with the body language because it's not
that you just sit and you should not
have any kind of movement many times you
know the candidate asks that whether we
can you know move uh hands or we can
move
our body the thing is that
while expressing yourself suppose a
question asked you should not be make
your body stiff a bit of hand movement
is always welcome that shows that you
are honest and also uh you you are you
are like
you're candid in that way a bit of hand
movement is absolutely all right like a
hand gesture uh touching finger this
sometimes you know you are saying that
number one this number two suppose you
have to say some data that number one is
this number two is this you can easily
use your finger and punching fingertips
and clasping palms and moving you know
fingers with your speaking in perfectly
it is absolutely okay you should not you
know stand like a stiff that is
stiffness shows that you are not natural
so be as natural as it is possible
because interview itself says that
you're you it is a kind of conversation
it's the only difference is that you you
you talk to your friends in an informal
way here it is little formal and it is
little structure so
uh if you if you uh you know change your
body posture time to time then what it
will show that you you are lacking you
know
confidence you are a little nervous so
you can move your hands you can always
nod but the problem is that you should
not change your position because
frequently if you change your position
that it will give a kind of you know
indication that you are bored with the
interview you did not like it or you are
not interested so this way you can you
can face it like uh but when it is the
online because post kobe the scenario
has little change so when it is online
then you have to always see that whether
it is properly you know lighted your
face is visible your you know voice is
heard so these are the different
differences when it is a face to face so
your entire body is seen by the
interviewer but when it is the online as
as we are you know interacting i am not
able to see you you are also not able to
see me you know properly you are just
seeing up in a portion of my body so
there uh you have to be very particular
in having that your face should be
properly lighted this much portion of
your body should be visible so this is
important
then comes that behavioral aspect and
attitude these two are very very an
important trait that how you respond or
react to a situation sometimes the
interviewer will be you know giving you
some situation and how you handle that
situation so that is also you know one
of the
criteria of selection or rejection of
the candidate so it is always said that
you should not react to any situation
rather you should respond to the
reaction is little bit you know negative
in connotation then comes that
professionalism
professionalism is also very very
important that though you can be you
know
comfortable as well as natural but this
professionalism should not be i mean
ignored like uh and it should be
following i'm just giving an example uh
there was uh like in 2019 itself uh
there was one candidate
uh whose mother whose parents both
whose parents died uh in a road accident
and his interview was a week after this
uh you know unfortunate incident so in
india it is uh the custom that uh after
the you know date of the parents you
have to shave your head
and
you you go to the and that fellow went
to the interview hall with his launcher
head so naturally the interviewer asked
that what happened
because in maybe in other country it can
be taken as a fashion statement but in
india if you happen to see anyone with
taunt your head that means uh you know
there is some some mishap has happened
so uh the interviewer asked that what
has happened that you you have shaven
your head
and he said that i lost my parents a
week before this interview and after
that he did not say anything so here it
is very very important that
professionalism because you should not
forget that why you are there
you should not get personal that if
something is out or something happens
during you know coming sometimes you are
you know suppose you're late or
something something anything you know
happens then you you just you know you
say something and in a sentence or
or two you should finish that personal
part and then you come back to the
interview so this professionalism is
always appreciated and yes you should be
on time because this is always you know
expected from the interview we views
that they should come on time because
many times it happens that the names are
announced and that candidate is not
there and this is always taken as a
negative you know uh
personality
then comes that ask yourself this is a
very very important question that
maybe you have got uh some you know uh
qualification you are you have done your
you know graduation maybe the post
ration also you have got several years
of you know experience
but
it is always recommended that you should
ask yourself from time to time is there
something uh missing in my personality
is there something missing in my uh cv
something to be added
why i'm
not employed yet
or i am unemployable so these two are
two different things and every candidate
everyone who who is seeking a proper job
should always ask again and again and
look at the trade what exactly to be
done what extra you know it is uh needed
uh to be employable
where i'm lacking why i'm rejecting
rejected all the times and the first
time interviewers interview also they
should they should also think of that
whether i am an unemployed person or or
am an employable person so it is a tough
you know question to ask yourself
because
uh we do not want to hear that i am not
employable but it is
something that we should work upon
then
the pre and post kobe scenario there are
certain things in interview that you
have to follow irrespective of you know
kobe
but there are certain things that are
important that this emphasis on uh pre
uh post kobe what happened that uh
online interviews uh have increased so
people are now they are working from
home
then we need to be you know tech
friendly otherwise it will be very
difficult time to time we have to always
see that whether uh you know network is
proper or not
then uh one thing has happened like we
have already you know worked for two
years uh working from home so one hand
that it has saved us from this you know
traffic hazard and all
but on the other hand
uh
like all the time we have to be
available for the employer so it is that
we have to collect 24
7 availabilities there any time some
messages or you know
some some you know text posts pop up and
we have to immediately answer that
because it is expected from the
employees to do
and empathy empathy has also become you
know crucial
you know thing nowadays because um i
remember that last time when i was there
as a board member in an interview so uh
one candidate was asked we usually ask
about this
post-publishing scenario that how did
you spend what all happened were you
positive or not sometimes you know this
kind of questions and there uh if such
questions are asked by the employer you
should should not highlight
on the trouble or the you know trauma
that you have faced it you have to talk
about that how you have contributed to
solving the problem how you have been
able to help your neighbors how have you
been able to help
your friends and all so you see in india
especially we had you know ah
shortages of bed in hospital we have
shortage because going by the huge
population the way we have managed it is
really commendable but still we have
faced the you know shortage of oxygen
cylinders and all
so there you have to highlight that
which way you have helped others
like this is very important because
usually what happens if such you know
questions are asked and nowadays
they are asked so then you have to
answer this way that which way you have
contributed rather than highlighting
that how you suffered
and how how you i over uh came this
situation so this is a an important
aspect that you have to remember then a
checklist that i have earlier also said
that
when it is an online interview like the
online interview trend has you know gone
up so check your equipment it's very
very important that before you start
like 15
minutes before that you have to have
like we also had a dry run before this
end you know session today so it is very
important that check your
equipment first
then light and sound both you check
whether you are properly visible whether
you are you know able um and properly
audible then you have to pick a quiet
place because
uh you know many times it also happens
that you are staying in a hostel and
from there you have to you know face
this interviews many times your house
you it doesn't have you know quiet place
so you have to just see that is there
any place that you can have for say an r
so please find that place you should not
have any
place where people will be walking from
your back and that is very distracting
and that is very bad
then position of camera is also
important that how much portion of your
body should be visible so we have one
phase time there
on your computer so then you see that
and you check before that how much
portion of your body should be you know
visible so that you should look
presentable because your entire body is
not visible so
whichever you know portion till so it is
visible so you have to see that you must
be presentable then check your internet
connection again and again and make sure
that which portion many times if your
house is little in a wi-fi then a
particular place you will find that it
is running very nicely and if you go
little far then ah there is the
disturbance so you have to go near that
and sit properly and
start this then background as i said
that background should be like you can
have a
curtain or you can have plain wall so
that uh there is no distraction so plain
wall
is there or you can have a curtain and a
dry run a dry run is a must suppose your
interview before that you must have dry
done with your friend or anyone so that
is an important aspect you can have you
can you know
send a link you can create schedule
a link and then you can send any friend
and you say that you whether you're
properly audible whether you're properly
visible that is a quick checklist before
the interview
then comes that uh frequently asked
questions as i said that practice
practice practice so there are certain
questions you know almost always asked
that uh you you begin the you know
interview with how are you doing how are
you today actually the interviewer is
not very much bothered how you are today
but this is just ask for the sake of
asking to make you comfortable so that
you and there you should not give an
elaborative answer that well this
happened and so usually it is a small
you know plain knot and give a smile i'm
great i'm good
and even if you're not just you can add
that i'm good but i had little
difficulty in reaching this you know
place you can say like that but after
that you should not make an elaborate
you know statement uh answering this
question then comes the very important
question is that introduce yourself on
or tell us something about yourself so
this you know requires lot of practice
and you should write down first about
yourself and please pick up those things
that you actually want the interviewer
to know is like some about you that you
are academy you should always start with
your educational qualification your
academic record that what are the
academic achievement and all then you
can also talk about your family
background and then you should also talk
about your hobbies and some achievements
if you have
then key strength
you have like what are the strength why
do you want to join us
and why should we hire you and your plan
ahead that what whatever your dreams are
that you
you usually they asked it and these
questions should be answered like uh as
how are you today i said a smile and
answer introduce yourself education
family hobbies and achievements you have
to talk about then create strengths
that team player on any you just select
i have shown you so many traits you can
go back to the previous slides so when
it is talked about the key strength then
you can i'm taking you to the my you
know previous slide that you can pick up
any from here
and you can pick up maybe a couple of
from here and then you have your answer
the key strength and then you connect i
i last uh i have said earlier also that
you should not take any trade that you
are not able to connect
with your own personality as well as the
qualification you have and the
organization so you should pick those
traits which are like beneficial both
ways do you to your organization and it
must match with your academic record as
well
then uh why do you want to join us so
this is very very important because any
organization
is interested in knowing that why why do
you want to come so here you have to
have a thorough research
about the organization so naturally if
you have applied somewhere and you have
been you know called so you should know
everything about it you should check the
website you can also see that if the
media has anything to say about that
organization any publication any any
news channel showing something about it
checking but checking the website is a
must
so most of the time that any
organization they
time to time keep on updating their
website so it is
like always it is a must that you should
go through the website
about it and
you see that which way your
qualification matches with the
organizational goal so that way you can
have your proper answer then why should
we hire you here also you have to talk
about your strength those you know
particular trace those particular
strengths that you see that is matching
with the organization so maybe the
organization is like uh
is working on something and you are you
you are talented and you are talking
about some strength that is not at all
required there so it is all useless you
should you should not even talk about
that so you should see that which
particular because we all have it's not
that we are just one strength we have
several key strengths but
you have to be very particular in
choosing the strength
that must
be the additional goal of that
particular company who are there for
interview so this is a must then goes
where do you see yourself in five years
this is a question and it's a difficult
you know a question we call because it
any employer who is
you know planning to hire is satisfied
with your answer and has decided to hire
so will not like you to leave that
organization so you have to talk about
even if you are planning you have to
talk about that which way
in five years you will be working with
the organization you will be working you
know gaining experience you will develop
you know team uh spirit uh how can you
be a team leader in the same
organization you can also say that uh
which way you can work on different
projects from one project to the other
project of the organization so these are
the ways you can talk about your you
know five-year planning
and
then
that how you you describe and sometimes
the tricky question is that how your
friends and how your neighbors describe
you so here also you can take some of
the you know key strengths that you feel
that is important and you genuinely feel
that it it happens and sometimes you
have to develop as i said that there are
some saturated states that we do not
have some innovations can be also you
know acquired there are some choice that
we are born with some talents you know
we call it god gifted but there are
certain traits that we can always you
know um acquire so we have to see that
whether we can acquire team you know
can be a team player many times it also
happens that we are little introvert we
don't feel like you know communicating
with people but
when you wish to you know work with some
organization you have to you have to
develop that you know a skill so how you
you have to start you know interacting
with people so one at a time first with
one
person then with three person four
persons in this day you have to develop
then uh
patience is another thing you know
that's very
very much important and uh you you you
have to have that communication skills
that how comfortable you are
communicating with people because many
times you know without communication you
cannot build a team and if you're not
able to build the team the trust will
also not be built so you need to work
hard on your communication and then uh
one more important thing is that is many
times and most of the time i have seen
that the employers also ask when the
employer is satisfied with the way you
have answered the questions then
employers ask you that do you have any
question and what are your expectation
from us so that question has to be
handled very you know nicely you have to
prepare some you know questions for them
to ask
that these are the questions you are
planning to ask maybe that what is the
expectation
uh the salary
the
growth and all you have to talk about
that especially a project that what is
the you know
the plan and the organizational goal of
that company you show your interest and
if you ask three four questions
regarding that particular organization
then employer will also feel that yes uh
yeah you are interested and this is the
right candidate but if you say no i
don't have any question to ask that
shows literally
that you are not interested or maybe you
know everything about the organization
so
this is not the right answer that any
candidate should say uh to the
interviewer so these are certain things
that you have to always keep in your
mind and interview is not something that
we should be scared or for the
frightened it is only that
a bit of you know practice required some
questions you have to keep your mind you
have to work on your body you have to
work on your non verbal you know
communication because the see
what you say
and uh and how your body responds to
that particular thing is very very
important it must align with your body
if you're saying something and your body
is different then it will never be a you
know good sign so you should see that
whether your eyes are having you know
proper eye contact is there uh
you are you know looking uh you're
passively it is not that you have to
give you know a stunned look at the
interviewer but yes eye to eye contact
is a must
and
you should also think that uh you know
wearing a smile is always good that
shows your positive you know attitude
you are taking the questions very nicely
you are smiling and answer suppose uh
sometimes it also happen that you do not
understand the question so be very
honest without understanding the
question you should never ever you know
try to attempt that answer you can
always ask that
sorry pardon you
you can always i know ask could you
please repeat the question i couldn't
get you properly so an interviewer are
also not that bad that they'll not
repeat for you so this is uh the way but
never uh ever you know try to
fool giving you know falsify is never
done so
you do not know the answer and then you
just you know try to you know answer no
then it's it's really bad so genuineness
is always appreciated and if you're
lying or or you are you know telling
know rightly that answers are coming
from your heart so interviewers are that
is smart to find out so never try to
falsify it so there are certain things
that you have to keep your mind and it
is
not at all uh
i say that very tough thing and it is
also not a cakewalk that you just go and
and people you might have you know a
plus plus grade you know an academy but
still if you are not prepared you are
not able to answer well then you there
is a possibility that you are not only
not at all you know um selected but if
you prepare well
practice well then uh there is no
question that you are not selected but
one
question that i always say ask yourself
whether you
are just unemployed or you are
unemployable
what are the traits to be you know
inculcated what are the traits to be you
know acquired
it's very very important so can we have
some questions
okay
are you asking to take some questions
from the audience
yes yes we can have it
okay
so we've had a number of questions
coming in and yes it was going yeah it
was like no on and i was just one-sided
and since i'm not able to stay
like it is
um let me
read some back to you um
yes so
cyan asks a basic question uh i think
everybody deals with it at one point or
another which is sometimes it happens to
nervousness
it becomes hard to find the right answer
how do you
prepare yourself to be more comfortable
in a nervous situation
so
it is uh cheyenne who asked
us uh yeah
uh yeah okay uh cheyenne um
everyone is little bit of nervous if
somebody says that i'm not at all
nervous you you take it that that person
is lying a bit of nervousness is fine
that shows that you are you know taking
it seriously
but
uh if you are not prepared
then
you are actually nervous
the thing is that
before any
interview as i have shown in my previous
slide also that you have to practice a
lot
because many times you are little i i do
not know if you are little introvert
these problems comes you know when you
are introvert you do not feel you don't
feel like talking to people
you are locked in a room reading books
or watching you know television
and you you do not like that so then
suddenly people come and uh start you
know sending you volume of questions and
you get nervous the best way is that you
have to practice with somebody maybe
your friend may be somebody from your
family that you have these questions and
you try to reply all the time and if
this happens or and you you can also
attain some mock interviews and in mock
interviews they will tell you that where
you lack because sometimes it also
happens that there are some people you
know uh
they are not very comfortable uh
answering uh sitting
and
they because most of the time they are
in on television
and they are you know talking on phone
so phone they are very comfortable the
moment they come you know face to face
communication face to face you know
conversation they are not comfortable so
for this say you have to you know uh i
mean uh some market you should attend
some you know mock interview and there
are so many people who organize mock
interviews for the job seekers please do
attend and
even if you don't attend but i would say
that you can have some family friend uh
maybe some you know friend of yours
you ask your friends to ask the
questions okay that way nervousness will
go and practice is the only thing
that because
if you do not practice and you just go
to face interview then anyone will you
know feel down business
okay
uh we have a couple of questions
um we have a couple of questions from
people who are
dealing with periods of unemployment
akash who's been unemployed for a short
while and then
um we also have abhi who asks about
an employment gap for two years or more
so what approach would you take in an
interview when someone asks about that
see they cannot be uh one answer to it
and what actually uh well what made you
you know drop it whether you like
uh
uh
fired by the organization why did you
have this gap
because everyone has different reason
for that
so maybe you can you have you know
continued your study maybe you have done
something
so you have to do because this gap is
never appreciated because it is said
that if you sit back home then you are
not employable
so if there is a gap you see that any
course that you can do you have to
justify the gap
and many times we've said that no you
are ill or something has happened that
doesn't work at all so you have to see
that
you have done something you have done
some you know course some certificate
course and all because gaps are never
lied
by the employer
and everyone has a different
you know
everyone has a different reason for this
gap and it cannot be one you know
ready-made answer that
how it was you know why this happened
we have several questions
yeah i think that that um
i think that addresses the question we
have several questions about
dealing with salary questions and
whether it's appropriate to negotiate
about salary during an interview
yes
of course see uh you remember that if
you are
seeking the job
the organization is also looking for
somebody like you
so this is important that
you must
negotiate your salary so it shows that
you are confident and you are able to
appraise yourself so you are you feel
free to negotiate
we have this is good also
um
we have some questions also about
i hope
yeah
um
so we have also questions about uh
the question the
typical interview question about
weaknesses if somebody asks
you know what is your weakness or
list three weaknesses you have
what would you advise
yes
you know he or she doesn't have any
weakness that is a white lie so you can
all get your weakness and you say that
due to that weakness uh what has
happened suppose you know um there was
one candidate say that punctuality is
the weakness
and uh
nowadays
you know most of the time people are not
that punctual so you can say that
punctuality i'm i'm very much you know
to the time and i'm punctual for this i
have to suffer a lot whichever place i
go i have to wait but still since it is
my you know weakness i cannot you know
do it and sometimes you can say that yes
i get a little nervous and i'm working
on it i'm looking emotional i'm working
on it
but don't ever say that you don't have
any weakness
you can say that
except and i'm working on it
um
has a question uh he's
uh
is educated in the finance field but
wants to switch into the hr field and
has a
question that always comes up in every
interview which is
why do you want to switch careers
so what kinds of uh
approach can can character take for that
a switching career means like from one
organization to the other
then one thing is that stagnancy is
there like you felt that your
your
talent is not properly explored not
properly exploited that's why you are
switching and you also felt a kind of a
stagnancy and you felt that if you
continue with the same thing you won't
be that happy and you wanted to explore
that make sense
um
isn't a degree a necessary thing for
employment these days or
can you
substitute a
postgraduate
type of certification a skills
certification with experience
it it varies from organization to
organization like in some of the places
it is just after graduation
you can uh be employed but in some of
the places you need to be a little you
know more experienced what happens in
most of the time in graduation level we
understand a lot of something
like aware of something or maybe uh
yes basically it is what of something
but when you do post graduation on the
same subject then you will start
understanding the why of something that
particular paper or the how of something
so in some of the organization that why
part or that how part is important but
in some of the organization just after
graduation you can join like in mass
communication i am telling that in mass
communication suppose you are
able to write well you understand the
media house as well so even after
graduation you can join
so that is there and post graduation
that that makes you more mature you
understand the why part of it so from
organization to organization libraries
i can also mention that
something happened a couple of years ago
in the united states where
the united states government actually
issued a directive that said that they
want to put more emphasis on skills
demonstration
rather than degrees when they're hiring
so
there is a shift
that says you know we recognize that
sometimes people with a degree
don't necessarily have the skills
experience uh to do the job in question
so
you need to be able to demonstrate
uh both of those things
so that's a that's a trend that's
happening we have
um adam asks an interesting question
adam asks
how should you answer the question why
should we hire you
when the person asking is an employment
agency and you don't even know which
company
they're hiring for
this
am i supposed to answer this
yes please
yes that is what the question is as i
said that why should we hire you so for
this you have to uh understand the
organizational goal of that particular
company as i said earlier also that you
should go through
the entire website of the organization
you have applied for and then you see
that which particular trait is
matching with the organization goal of
that particular organization because
every organization has different you
know aims and objective and you have to
see that it is not just that one trait
that you have you have several traits
you have several key strengths but every
key strength is not necessary
a for any organization so what you have
to do is that
when you are applying and you have to
see that this question is going to ask
then you should see the organization
properly you should you know browse do
jupiter you know a bit of research you
do find out the you know uh objectives
and aims and then you see that this
particular
key strength that you have will match
more and then you have to highlight that
particular strength of yours that which
way that strength you are based with
that strength and that is
with that with the help of that strength
you are going to contribute to the
enhancement of the company
and in the particular case that uh adam
was asking about where
you're dealing with an employment agency
but you don't know the name of the
actual company they're hiring for it's
it's still a
similar
that is a little tricky but there also
you have to say the general traits that
you have and there you have to be very
honest suppose if you are
not
very hardworking
and then you say that you are
hardworking then after you know hiring
you you will be fired immediately
there are some people who cannot work
hard but they are smart you know work
smart so then you have to say that which
way whether you can work smart or you
can work hard
that's important so
self analysis is very important steward
like
many times it happens that we do not
know our strength and we just go so
before an interview you have to see that
actually what is your strength
actually what are you know inherent uh
traits of yours and this is very
important sometimes if we just go we do
not know we all are blessed with some
strength and that you have to explore so
first you explore yourself only then you
can explore you know the company you're
applying for that's very important
i can by the way mention
experience that i had when i was young
and
i i went for an interview for
the united states navy's
nuclear propulsion program
the idea was that
you had to pass
basic interview with a couple of
members of the service
um before you could
get through to the next levels of
interviews and ultimately with the the
admiral
um
and i did so
very very poorly on that interview i
it was if i had had this opportunity to
uh
to get briefed on interview tips and and
uh practice
i might be in an entirely different
field of career today but um
the
that does bring up a couple of questions
that have come in from the audience uh
are there resources that you can
recommend menardi for um
um
practicing and or mock interviewing
i would suggest that everyone must read
newspapers
it's very important that
like one hand that you improve your
communication by reading the newspaper
loudly and on the other hand that you
also are abreast of all the things
happening around the world many times
you know people might ask you that what
is your take on
this russia ukraine war
or what is your take on
on any of the particular international
issue so you should be able to answer i
am not saying that you have to we know
support a particular organization or or
or don't support only thing is that you
have to you know answer that thing new
being a neutral you know watcher or a
reader so this newspaper reading helps a
lot and read and write reading and
writing and you know make person people
perfect i say that practice makes a man
perfect and women as well
um
muhammad asks an interesting question
and i think a lot of people have
this idea on their mind which is
if you're working at a company and
you're not happy
so you go to to give an interview at a
new company what are some of the things
you should keep in mind when you're
interviewing at the new company
this is the blunder that most of the
time job seekers do
they uh start you know many times
because i i've been bored of many of
their organizations they hire me as a
board member so we ask that what is your
past you know experience with the part
organization that you are working they
start saying all bad things about the
organization so
this is not done
you are not supposed to say anything
wrong about your previous organization
because if you say that then what will
happen this center the particular
organization you have come for the
interview they might think that you are
going to do the same thing after you
leave this place
so never ever say you simply say that
you wanted to explore you you felt that
your talent was not particular you know
properly utilized you were you know
underutilized or maybe you you felt
little bit of stagnancy that's why you
are you know going for never ever say
that you're not not happy you are
unhappy these are not not the terms that
you should use in any of the interviews
you face
yeah i think that that's
so important because
whatever you're going to say about
your current job
they know that you'll say something
similar about them
uh in your new job so
people get get very nervous about that
um deepak asks
yeah deepak asks a question um
about switching from a teaching career
uh into data science and data analysis
is
do you have any opinion on whether
that's a good
decision or a good career path to look
at
i couldn't get that from teaching to
into data science and data analysis
okay okay that's fine you see it all
depends on your personal you know
comfort level
like uh
if you love teaching
and then you wish to suddenly you know
switch over to that particular job that
you're thinking in your mind that okay
that will give you a lot of money
money-wise it is very good but again
the most important thing is whether you
are comfortable because teaching is
absolutely a different you know job and
become becoming a data analyst or
anything for that matter is a different
thing so you have to see that
where which particular profession you
are able to give your best that is also
there make because many times you know
for a cup you know little bit of you
know more money is offered and you leave
your job and then you start after you
know a couple of months you start
regretting because you're not able to
give your best so it is also very
important to understand yourself because
no no one else can answer this for you
you have to see your own level that
where you are like
it's not only that money it is also that
whether you're liking your job because
you can stick to a particular job only
when you like
yeah exactly you and and if you have a
passion
for solving problems in in data science
or doing data analysis
then it makes sense to look at that as a
field but if your passion is
interacting with the people and helping
them understand concepts
um
you know you might want to look at a way
to
continue to teach but incorporate these
other
passions into that
yes um
and i think
we have uh before we finish we have uh
one other general question area a couple
of people have asked about
um how to dress for success with is it
necessary to wear a tie to an interview
what kinds of advice would you give
people for
uh being presentable in their in their
dress
of that usual
yeah
yes yes it's it's important to first
that again i would say that it uh you
should wear what is comfortable and you
should always wear formal you are not
supposed to wear anything like casual it
should be proper shirt and you have the
trousers and
from the time there are some people who
are not that comfortable you can go
without wearing tie also but again i
would say that you should see
that particular organization that what
the you know employees wear
if you see that everyone wears tie there
then it i would suggest that you should
wear tie even if you are not so
comfortable and don't try that tie on
the that day so if you you see that you
have to wear tie then you please
practice bearing time because many times
it happens that it jokes and you are not
that comfortable so you should practice
if at all it is necessary otherwise thai
is not at all necessary
and and it really is it gets to the
question of company culture because
there are some places where
wearing it's
yeah we're wearing a tie
makes you look silly
but there's other places where not
wearing a tie makes you look
unprofessional so it really it really
does depend on who you're talking to and
what their what their
company culture is
um
we're running out of time so i'm going
to have to apologize to everyone there's
just dozens of questions coming in that
we can't get to but i wanted to give you
time midnight i know that you had an
exercise that you wanted to go through
is that through
we should have started the interaction
uh earlier
oh
um are are you running out of time as
well or did you want to do the uh the
other um yes i can think is a couple of
questions
if it allows
oh sure um if you have time then yeah um
we have a question um
from someone who asked
how to deal with anger management in an
interview
anger management
yes
anger management
can be done through in india we do
meditation that's very very important
like if you do you know wake up in the
morning
and
you be silent for a while
then you start meditating
and you start thinking that how you are
going to spend your time what happens
usually since
we are not able to manage
we are always in a hurry to do and we
take a lot of things in a go so that
time since you're not able to manage and
you have to you know vent out
your
you are in inability to manage the
things that's why you have you you are
angry so the best thing is that you
should plan ahead like before going to
bed you make a list things to do
and next
day you see that you are able to do
those things
and if you missed one thing then you
also see that whether that particular
task can be carried forward
then
next day you should start taking those
things then what will happen
if you are you know little you know make
your life little methodical it is
structured then automatically you will
be able to manage anger it is anger is
nothing but your inner frustration and
you want to just vent out why don't you
get angry uh you know at the person who
is senior to you
you always show your anger to your
subordinates
or the people who you can shout at
so it shows that it can be managed
anger management is in our hand
it is a verb
yeah because suppose if it is out of
control then why don't you shout at your
boss
you never shout at your boss
you do not shout at your parents you do
not shout at
your seniors you are shouting at your
juniors you are shouting at children so
that shows that you are able to manage
you are able to manage you are extremely
angry with your boss still you do not do
that
right
right
and it's something that
i would recommend never showing if you
are able to manage only things that you
want to vent out and for this keep
breathing yeah big breathing helps a lot
and i would i would recommend that you
never
yeah i'd say
um never um show anger during an
interview i mean that's yes
it's
it's a sometimes they judge also they
will try to irritate you or sometimes
they try to poke you but there you have
to take it with a pinch of salt enjoy
yeah and you and they want to see that
you you have the ability to deal with
difficult situations and be patient
um
when when
you are in an interview and you
either don't have an answer to the
question at all
or the answer isn't coming to mind
what is the best way to approach that
should you simply honestly say i do not
know the answer to that or
do you
um
know essentially play for time in order
in order to give yourself a chance to
think of the answer
if you do not at all know the answer you
do not understand the question there are
two different things sometimes it also
happens that you do not understand the
question
then you can always request to simplify
for you paraphrase for you and after
paraphrasing also if you do not
understand the question then simply
declare very honestly that you do not
know it and you are not supposed to
answer everything like if they ask you
say uh 20 questions 25 questions if you
are not able to answer three questions
out of that it is absolutely fine
perfect
but be honest don't give wrong answers
um
we also have the the situation and and
the famous example is google
where companies will
where companies will ask you you know
questions that are unrelated to the job
but are
uh
based on
you know
gauging how well you can solve problems
or
even basic intelligence and what what
advice do you have for people to deal
with those kinds of questions
so
you can
actually what happens that such type of
when the questions come you try to
understand many times it also happens
that out of nervousness we say that
i don't know i'm sorry i do not know
when when you pause little and try to
say that what is there is there
something some hidden thing is there
that you are able to answer you are able
to you know get grasp it then then you
can always answer but if you see that
it's absolutely you have not heard about
it you have not read it uh you know
before then please it is better that you
do not answer only
and always say sorry
because if you uh give a wrong answer to
a question then you lose
the trust
that you are going to answer this way if
they hire you
nabeel asks an interesting question
which is if you are told a salary range
in the um
interview and it's not satisfactory how
can you politely reject the offer
you can uh you can always thank
you can thank them because they have
made their mind to hire you but somehow
you feel that this is not
communicate with the you know effort
that you are going to give to the
company you can always do that
but always thank
you
so at this point we're gonna i am gonna
um move from questions did you have um
that other um
application you wanted to demonstrate um
minotti or are we moving on
i i just wanted to have a
game with them but i think kahuti
doesn't how many uh
it is the fastest finger first you want
to play a game
yeah let us know in the chat if you'd
like to do a quick uh exercise with
menardi
yes or no
yeah a lot of yeses
okay a lot of yeses
fine so uh participants have you heard
about kahoot
have you heard about kahoot
yes and now we're getting knows so
we have some people
some people
yes yes
then what you do go to google
and type kahoot
and you can do that uh actually right
now
that is an exercise yeah it will take
just you know a
couple of
seconds only
can you see my screen
okay
so uh
any game pin is asked
what do you want to play i think it's
better
i think mind your tongue
because english language is common
though
we have different accent indians have
different accent americans have
different accent but it should not be
pronounced wrongly accent may be
different
so mind your tongue is there one game
starting
so
game pin is asked
just go to go
google
type kahoot
yes how many of you could
i think you have to do the registration
which asks for your
date of birth
hey
continue for free
yes
so gameplay gamepl
have to see whether it's allowing
is it
discover kahoots
enter the game
it's very simple just go to uh google
type kahoot
yes
sweetie
oh many have joined
lovely
lovely
stuart you to join
i'm looking for the i'm looking to try
to join yeah
okay
so good
it's lovely
many could join
great
okay
now i tell you the rule
that each question will have 20 seconds
fastest finger first
it's that which way you will be marked
your answer has to be you know correct
as well as you have to be very fast in
answering
so
still people are joining
so you can see the question
on the screen
and then you have to answer
there in kahoot
you have to switch the screen
immediately
the question will be there
here on the screen
and then you have to go back to kahoot
to answer them four options will be
there
am i clear
yes
these all are mcqs
many are there too
the advice to people joining is to go to
www dot
and that will give you a screen that
shows
how to put in the pin that's on the
screen there on one
okay
so
i think uh everyone
those who could join have joined so i
must say once again the rule that the
patients will be here on the screen here
you can see where the names are floating
and answer will be there the kahoot
where you have typed the game pinned
okay
so now
now we start
managing
this
i think you can start yeah begin to
start let them join
so it's on interview first
some questions i have taken from my
slide and some i have just sit
be fast
oh
we're typing it in oh here we go
sign up
next question
uh
so now it is marva morelli has gone down
next
if you wish you can take the screenshot
also
great
hit
kg is leading
joint
uh
stuart you your
second position very good
you have done well
i did not see the answers in advance so
okay
good
uh
very good
thank you i have a competitive streak
you're pretty fast
oh let's show the question
what
oh still your top
very good
that's
amazing
wow finally the last question is stuart
now okay
we have to clap for you
keeping my fingers crossed
so finally let's see
rolex
third
zamer
fourth and fifth rank
okay i apologize for being a bad host
and winning
that was a
that was a great game because it
made me
think about all of the
great advice that you've given through
the the presentation
really
really pulled it back so
thank you for adding that
yeah
so um i think
at this point we want to go back and
finish the webinar
do you have any last uh
last uh thoughts for the the
attendees
uh i just lastly i would like to say to
all of
uh you
that it is
not something that
you should panic
and this is not also a cakewalk
if you properly prepare you can easily
crack and one question you should always
ask yourself
that am i
just an unemployed guy
or i am unemployable
tough question
and
by the way if it's something that you've
uh answered that you're unemployable now
there's always steps you can take
to change that situation for yourself
so
i'm going to
go ahead and
finish off the webinar
where we're going to talk about
last question for the audience
which is
are you interested in learning
digital skills
i know that simply learn is in the
business of helping people learn digital
skills and
so we're very curious
webinar attendees
and what their interests are
so we'll give you about uh 20 more
seconds to
answer this quick quick poll
and it's all important to think about
you know when would you like to start
doing that so this is
if there are things that you need to add
to your personal tool kit to make you
a better candidate
always
consider that doing it sooner than later
is
a good plan
and with that
i will share the poll result
so there's a fairly even distribution of
you know what people want to learn about
but business project management data
science are the leading categories
and it's encouraging that uh
you know about two-thirds of the
audience does want to do this right away
or within at least in just the next
couple of months so
with
with that information
i just want to go on and say thank you
to menotti i will
put into the chat window
per uh linkedin
excuse me
bumble with my mouse
thank you stewart for this wonderful
opportunity i really enjoyed
and and thank you so much
you know for being here and being
generous with your time and your
knowledge
i think we got
hold on as i get this
in
there we go
that's it
so in your chat windows you'll be able
to see
monet's linkedin
url and be able to connect with her
through that
and
i just want to mention since so many of
you did ask about project management
program management
we do have a program which we which is
in conjunction with the university of
massachusetts amherst which is one of
america's leading
public universities it's a six month
postgraduate program in project
management
and
it covers
a whole host of
project management and
agile and
quality assurance techniques
it includes
earning a postgraduate certificate and
alumni association membership
from the university
and it's a step-by-step program that
takes you through in six months
all the way from the project management
professional certification to
agile
lean sigma six uh lean six sigma i
should say a green belt
um
understanding digital transformation and
finally a a capstone
project that ties together all of these
skills and it gives you a
really wonderful
background in project management
gives you expertise that you can show
off to a employer and
there's a set of no cost electives that
you can add based on your
level of interest so
i will put a link to that also into the
chat and
i invite you to check that out
and with that
please follow us on our social media
channels at simplylearn on facebook and
twitter
and simply learn on linkedin
and that concludes our webinar for
today's thank you all very much for
being here
and
thanks again monadi
bye-bye
you